now it's time for tonight's hashtagwars
the seventh season of Game of Thrones
there's a third episode that's coming
Sunday and fans are hoping the big
questions will finally be answered
will Sam Charlie cure greyscale who will
be revealed is the three heads of the
Dragon ones who doors big swinging dick
real or was it a prosthetic I can answer
the last one well Carla either way Hodor
season premiere featured a polarizing
cameo from ginger crooner ed Sheeran
which had us wondering what if other
celebrities invaded the land of Westeros
that is why tonight's hashtag is Game of
Thrones celebs examples might be Betty
white Walker or alternatively Kanye
Westeros I went to put 30 seconds on the
clock and begin
Amanda that's so three-eyed Raven yes
Lloyd that gentleman Tywin gell-mann
Esther yes boys nice Mac Tyrell the
Creator yes boys okay me tell Mantha
Stark
yes I feel with you right boo boo
Gooding jr. yeah very good point Amanda
Rihanna of Tarth yes Boyd right Kelvin
right Clifford avatar nice right back
Dwayne is a mountain John yes Amanda ho
Dora the Explorer yes beyond Gelman yes
you just put your last name after Dion's
name back chip Harrington yes very nice
done
Brett king joffrey Brett Gelman